hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay
I learned a fun new trick that I
probably should have learned a long time
ago but I got my fire stick here I'll
bring it oh oh oh what what that oh you
want some right in the Millia okay I
miss horribly oh give me one of your hey
shut up give me one of your not that you
me that that's that oh here we go whoa
that's a new one
oh but I bet you got just the same
ha ha got ya gimme gimme all right
through the what ha ha
oh yeah haha there's another one behind
you sir oh that was nothing why don't
you give me a challenge zombie stuff
apparently items cut out from your body
my stuff
house are you Oh Jimmy stump
gimme oh ah no I want that I must have
been a big enemy gave me one of those um
I have two schematics when why do I have
two schematics I don't need to see bench
I'm at full health I'll use this why not
I need stasis it's a good use right Oh
petal Oh such a good Explorer guy I am
boom rippers blades wired boom ah too
many Ripper blades not even using it
condition sequence initiated
oh okay that's what I'm supposed to do
oh hey hey ha ha oh hello okay rearrange
oh I can ha ha oh you're so oh no no no
no no hey back up back off ah she'll oh
wow okay you mean give me a cloth
nothing stop
whose dead party
Oh full-auto this [ __ ]
oh one more up wait
no gimme damn fine item ok do a
front-flip to celebrate your depth
that's and y'all know giving experience
I think it's companies to it already
anymore
I tasted my head we picked up
that goes in a very straight line almost
at it
how's it I guess
it's [ __ ] hey Ron wired and
functional finally some good news
yeah get it transmitted Briggs Isaac I'm
gonna take us back into adjudication
wait wait we're not safe yet
of course not that sister is offline on
the way up the ship's going to pass
through a debris field thrown it from
the planet crack ripped pieces unless
you restart it okay god damn it I'll
start working on it from here
Isaac meet me at the bridge you can do
more good here than I can yeah okay
finally meet up with one of my teammates
but as soon as I get there they're gonna
be dead guarantee that it's like
non-stop one thing after the other
breaks hey baby
uh-huh
oh wait Nestle am i coming up a
different way that I came down I must be
right find this door whoa whoa hey
that's a good one yes that was a good
one
okay was it just waiting for me to turn
around
okay all right whatever whatever doesn't
matter
oh my microphone out of place all right
what did I guess I need offload I'm
never gonna lose all my health am i
selling that stuff and I need to use one
of those blah blah blah oh my god I need
to get rid of some of this stuff we've
got too much ammo I'm never gonna use it
all
ladies plasma Energy's gone
and ah friggin finals and I'm gonna get
more of these power news I can't I have
the money
dolla dolla bill y'all use one of the
med packs little Sabo station alright
where yep
dude f all right where am I going now
I'll back to the tram station ah F
bloody you Yeah right and then we're
moving on I think this finishes up the
chapter Booya I'm do bass oh look at
that mother
alright that's enough of that no I just
saved him okay
alright chapter four obliteration
imminent could you make a more dire name
for a chapter obliteration imminent
alright whatever
Oh bring it on so ready no more monsters
popping out while I'm shopping okay come
in Kendra is right
uh-huh the 80s is completely shot I'll
need your help to fix this okay
Kendra if you can hear me see if you can
get this a ship reports it sounds like
you're better access from there when
were you going to tell us about the
artifact Hammond this marker I don't
know anything about that it's referenced
in the captain's records they brought it
up from the planet it's on the ship in
cargo they think it's a Balian origin
but don't know rate I'll it is really
CEC didn't know anything about it you're
lying I am NOT the bad guy here yeah
y'all thank you right now you're gonna
have to trust but I don't know anything
about it yes you do you do weave into
the debris field get to the captain's
desk I'll explain everything later
coming down okay it's always the
military guy that's on that he knows
more than he's letting on just like
military discipline not to tell okay hey
Oh
get out here buddy
no I met with me hey you don't wanna
mess with me you don't want to mess with
me way too tough way too tough okay why
I touch this door huh all right okay
level three suit maybe level three no
earn all right
gosh I need to start using my Ripper cuz
god I don't have a lot of ammo for it
does the alt fire for a Ripper
this is great okay whoa hey
that seems like a problem oh just lose
just lose oxygen or something
I think impact on the bridge right at
your feet no kidding being heavy damage
but containment look solid life support
is stabilized we got two Canadians
working yeah no kidding and guess who's
gonna do it
me you why can't I sit on the bridge and
let you guys go fix
Oh because they probably died oh [ __ ]
sausage going crazy yep
yummy yummy monsters hmm
I got a saw that I haven't been using
yeah oh yeah
did that Oh Isaac dad my Lily place is
making me jumpy luckily meeting up with
one of my teammates come through the
roof and he's not dead
look monster I know Kendra doesn't trust
me but I don't know anything about a
marker or anything else this is supposed
to be a repair mission plain and simple
yes sure buddy this mask is the asteroid
defense system huh I can fix these moves
and the main power routing is shot
you're gonna have to reroute them
manually through at least three junction
boxes to activate the primary can yeah
okay but first you need to activate the
atrium elevators from bridge security
you can use them to get the junction
boxes
by the way Isaac be careful I saw
something out there I don't know what
and he got a glimpse yeah I saw it too
big really big really big okay all right
I get a new objective or something send
me on another mission man anyway I got a
posite here
thank you guys so much for watching and
I will see you in the next part
bye bye